race is directed by Stephen Hopkins and
is the true story of Jesse Owens a
runner from Northeastern Ohio who
eventually went on to make history at
the 1936 Olympics and when I saw the
name Stephen Hopkins I thought to myself
that looks familiar I need to look that
up right now
this is a guy who directed predator 2
and lost in space gratefully his skills
have improved since then because I
really enjoyed watching race and one of
the biggest reasons is because of
Stephan James he is really good in this
movie for two specific reasons he
captures the heart of Jesse Owens this
runner from Northeastern Ohio who just
really wanted to make a difference and
really wanted to help his family but he
also captures the most important element
of his character and that is the
conflict being an african-american at
that time was incredibly unreasonably
hard in every way we all know this it
was stupid stupid times the chance for
him to go to the Olympics being held in
Berlin where Adolf Hitler was currently
under reign was a huge huge statement
that he could make but he has a lot of
conflict about this because of the way
Hitler treated Blacks and Jews and tons
of other different religions that he
didn't agree with and he wonders if he
really should go at all or if he should
just boycott the Olympics entirely and
make that statement for his people and
for his family and that's where race
really shined for me the conflict there
that story and that element of this
movie was really riveting and that was
one of my favorite parts of this movie
because there are a lot of subplots
and when the film does conclude you
understand why these subplots were
necessary to tell the story correctly
but throughout the film they do appear a
bit broken the movie does have a hard
time making these numerous subplots feel
seamless there's a German director
trying to film the Olympics and she's
having a hard time convincing the Nazis
to give her the equipment necessary
there's a humungous ass nazi who's
trying to make everything hard on the
Jews and the african-americans who are
participating in the Olympics there's of
course Jesse Owens main story of trying
to become a better athlete he also has a
family back home there's also a woman he
meets that makes things a little bit
difficult for him and then there's Jason
Sudeikis as his coach there's a lot of
subplots in this film and sometimes the
movie has a hard time balancing all of
them they all need to be there to tell
this
correctly and they're mostly handled
well but that's my biggest issue with
this movie it is very long and it feels
long because those subplots are
improperly balanced it's easy to say
well this movie's over long well why is
it over long because parts of it were a
little bit boring because the actual
story wasn't as cohesive as it could
have been because you know if a movie is
good and you're enjoying everything
you're not going to really notice if
it's 2 hours and 14 minutes but if some
of the story elements could have used
some more work than you are gonna notice
it and it is gonna feel a little bit too
long but I touched on something and that
was Jason Sudeikis he really surprised
me in this movie he again proves that
comedians can work really well in a
dramatic movie because he was the one
element of this film I was confused
about I was like I don't know about that
when I saw the cast list and he really
was great he plays a coach that in the
past had similar opportunities that
Jesse Owens is now experiencing and
because of this and not obtaining those
goals he feels very broken and I thought
he gave her a really good performance so
between the two good lead performances
of Jason Sudeikis and Stefan James I
thought this was a very enjoyable movie
it is a little bit too long because some
of those story elements are not handled
as well as they could there is an
overabundance of subplots but they do
need to be there and that's really it I
had a great time with this movie and
it's also very well titled the title
race not just the sporting events but it
also touches on the bigger issues this
movie is talking about directly with a
person's race with the Nazis in Germany
and back in America the way it's
depicted there it was the perfect title
for this movie I'm gonna give race a B I
hope some people check this movie out
because I was the only person in the
theater and that was a little bit
disappointing although it was kind of
cool to have the whole theater to myself
I was expecting more people especially
since I am from Northeastern Ohio I've
heard about Jesse Owens my whole life so
it was really cool to see him depicted
well on-screen and I was expecting more
people from my area to come to this
movie and I hope some people see it
because it is worth your time stay tuned
for Sunday my next episode of retro
rewind is going to be for tremors I'm
relaunching that segment and I can't
wait to bring it to you guys you guys
are the best thank you if you liked this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes